[Music]
[Music]
good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show live
from westminster now
there appears to be more questions than
answers over cobit this morning
will a vaccine surge be enough to stop
the spread of the indian variant
what impact could it have on the next
phase of lockdown easing
and should we be flying abroad well the
eu is said to be keen to allow fully
vaccinated people to head to europe
without quarantine or
testing we'll see if the education
minister jillian keegan could clear
things up for us
in just a few minutes also ahead for you
interstellar opportunities at 10 to 9
we'll be talking to the international
director of the uk space agency
about a jobs boom in the sector
and a transatlantic curtain raiser as
theaters welcome back audiences
will talk to the playwright lucinda
coxton about a new production of her
show herding cats
which uses actors in london and los
angeles
that's what a quarter to ten it's
wednesday
the 19th of may the pandemics teenage
victims
inside the secure unit where mental
health nurses are dealing with
unprecedented levels of self-harm and
eating disorders community teams are
absolutely backlogged
people aren't having as many
face-to-face appointments everything's
done over like online and
i think a lot of our young people can
say it's so easy to lie and say you're
fine on an online appointment
should i stay or should i go ministers
mixed messages over foreign trips amid
reports that europe is ready to welcome
fully vaccinated travelers a failure to
plan
the spending watchdog says the
government was ill-prepared for the
scale of the coronavirus pandemic
conflict in the middle east fighting
continues between israeli and
palestinian forces with both sides
reporting more attacks
overnight the failures in a cover-up the
investigation which reveals the flaws in
some
reusable face masks
and it's a case of sunshine and showers
once again today but
later some areas will be mainly dry with
lots of sunshine
i'll have the details for you later in
the program
a very good morning to you for well over
a year now the coronavirus pandemic has
had an impact on
all of our lives and of course is
claimed many victims
some of those who've suffered have been
less visible than others including the
large number of young people
who've seen a deterioration in their
well-being
well two-thirds of young people say
their mental health got worse during the
lockdowns
they're more likely to have experienced
poor mental health than adults
and that has led to a doubling of
referrals for help with eating disorders
recent nhs data shows a four-fold
increase in the number of children and
young people waiting for urgent care
and a 129 increase in the number waiting
for routine
treatment over the last year our people
and politics correspondent nick martin
has spent the last three weeks with the
staff and patients of the pennine care
nhs
trust and just to warn you his report on
their work has references to self-harm
suicide and ligatures images of
self-harm
references to eating disorders and
pictures
of nasal gastric tubes
the first thing you notice here are the
locks
there are locks on every door
this is our airlock because a lot of the
young people are detained it's just an
extra security measure
so one door has to lock before the other
opens i see okay
inside it's an uneasy combination of
children's ward
and prison wing
[Applause]
50 milligrams of circulating which is an
antidepressant
50 milligrams of chlorine it's a
antipsychotic for low mood and suicide
radiation
this is a place where severe illness
meets
severe treatment
should we cover it up just so it doesn't
get infected yeah yeah
i've got to clean it off anyway come on
at least this will stop anything getting
into it
so this is horizon ward this is a 10
bedded unit um
six of these beds are for eating
disorders
it's 7am and night staff hand over to
the day team
she did tie a ligature at ten o'clock um
it was removed by the ligature knife
the physical observations were completed
there were no concerns
it was quite tight so she was gasping
for breath like afterwards
she did have a brief period of head
banging at eleven o'clock
we've followed the management plan went
in every five minutes
horizon is a secure psychiatric unit
for children and young people
and meal times can be difficult in a
place where no one wants to eat
it's the most difficult part of the day
first patients are offered food
if they refuse they're offered this
what's in it ultimately calories but
more than that it's like all the
nutrients
so vitamins minerals everything that the
body needs to sort of
function on a day-to-day basis
the pandemic is fueling an alarming rise
in eating disorders in the past year
cases have
doubled and demand for beds on wards
like this one
is up by a fifth she won't
come out at the moment sometimes it's
not long before they discover that a
patient
is refusing to eat are you sure there's
nothing we can do to help
because i know it's really difficult
when he's trying to beat it don't we not
come out for a little bit
nurse cat tries to support the youngster
but time has run out 15 minutes
draw the feed up and bring her out does
she know
yeah the clock is ticking yeah so the
young people are aware of it
they know the timings really well
this is what we call an ng tube it's
inserted through the nostril
goes up and then down the esophagus into
the stomach
and it allows us to syringe feed
it's the only way and either
you do something quite brutal or you let
a 14 year old 15 year old
become so physically compromised that
they could ultimately die or go into
organ failure
the eating disorder anorexia nervosa has
this young girl
in the tightest of grips
supported by nurses she's taken to a
room
and behind this door that high calorie
formula
is injected into the feeding tube
i don't know how to feel about it really
having having witnessed it this is the
end of the process and we've just seen
that young girl being marched down that
corridor by nurses
who describe this as not a battle
between nurse and patient
but a battle between nurse and eating
disorder
this girl doesn't want to eat but now
she's being
forced to eat
we're seeing a massive increase in young
people that are coming in and saying i
tried to get better at home
and the support just wasn't there
because the community teams are
absolutely backlogged
people aren't having as many
face-to-face appointments everything's
done over
like online and i think a lot of our
young people have been saying it's so
easy to lie and say you're fine on an
online appointment and it's not until
they get to the point where they're
probably bordering on coming in here
that we realize how severe things
actually are
but there's a problem there just aren't
enough
of these places to meet this surge in
demand
and so a crisis is now emerging
nick martin sky news
well look if you've been affected by any
of the issues in nick's report you can
talk to
the samaritans there on 116 123
or the eating disorder charity
beat now their helpline is 0808
801
let's talk to the education minister
jillian keegan morning to you look
it's hugely disturbing seeing what these
young people
are going through whether it's an eating
disorder or other
forms of of mental distress that they're
going through i mean clearly
there needs to be more done here what
can the government do
i mean it is very distressing and in
fact very familiar i have a
family friend who went through exactly
that experience so it was uh distressing
actually to watch um i mean obviously
the government's putting a lot
more emphasis on mental health a lot
more support into mental health and a
lot more investment into mental health
and also investment into mental health
at schools but when you get to this
point which is highly specialist
um and you know this is incredibly
dangerous
then obviously you know it's really
about getting that support to young
people
at the right time and you know and it is
it is distressing but also it is
worrying that there is an increase
in this um you know and mental health in
general the pandemic has
taken a terrible toll um on many of our
young people but
uh yeah it was it was particularly
distressing yes
i mean what what we're seeing there
though is is a
lack of facilities to provide the urgent
care that young people need now this may
have been unexpected
and unexpected side effect of of the
pandemic but
because those you know those beds those
specialist wards
are needed urgently will the government
can you say the government will look
into this
yes and and we have been looking into
this i mean this has been recognized
as an issue and to be honest it's it's
something that
even before the pandemic um was was was
something that we were concerned about
um and you know those highly specialized
beds that you saw
in your clip um you know there aren't
there aren't enough of them
and in particular access around the
country
um but yes it is definitely something
that we have
um a huge focus on uh mental health in
general but
eating disorders self-harm and young
people's mental health
is particularly concerning
look can i ask you about the indian
variant how concerned
is the government at the way the indian
variant
has appeared across the uk and now now
may be spreading
it what can be done is surge vaccination
going to be enough
i mean obviously these new variants are
always
the center of our concern um you know
that's that's
the thing that's you know we've always
said um as we
as we emerge from the pandemic as we get
uh most of our country vaccinated
these are always the things that we need
to be really um wary about
it looks like there's good news that the
vaccines work against this variant
but um you know obviously surge
vaccinations
surge testing all the things we've got
in place you know
are part of our system working and our
genome sequencing
has actually allowed us to actually
identify this variant
uh quite quickly um and be able to act
and that's really all you can do with a
virus like this
when you've got something that can
mutate there's thousands of variants of
this well
forgive me it's not it's not all you can
do i mean the the problem you've got
here and surge vaccination
could well have a very big effect but
not for another three weeks
you know it's going to take three weeks
for that first jab to to even begin to
kick in
what needs to be done before that i mean
because what i mean one expert from from
sage
doctor zubaida hack has said to quota it
is astonishing the prime minister has
gone ahead with the
third stage of the road map given the
government didn't pass
all four tests for easing the roadmap
because this is a variant of concern
of course but this you know everything
is about balancing risk
and the the data we have the data we
have at the moment
the um the scientists that we work with
we've taken
that decision that you know this this
gentle unlocking and by the way you know
last night
uh this this week's um unlocking as it
were
is effectively being able to meet six
people inside um
so you know it's not exactly um you know
sort of
unlocking everything it is a cautious
step along
what what has been quite a long road map
uh as we emerge out of the vaccine at
the virus so you know these are all
balanced risks they're balanced risks
but we do believe that people this is
now the time for
personal responsibility cautious
personal responsibility the british
public have been amazing
both in getting the vaccine and uh you
know
admit adhering to all the lockdown rules
they've been
absolutely amazing but you know this
first step
is the first step in the next road of
the journey and
we think it's the right step yeah but
i mean you say it is a variant of
concern which
you know does question whether the four
key tests for for releasing the lockdown
this last monday were actually met
but even in terms of the the indian
strain itself i mean should the
government have acted sooner
in in in putting india on a red list i
mean never mind the fact that we're
still getting
hundreds of flights heading in from
india at the moment
well this variant of concern was
actually identified about two weeks
after
we put india on the red list so it was
identified it was checked and about two
it was about two weeks after we put
india on the
red list that it was this variant of
concern that was
identified and that's what we're dealing
with if you think we can go back in time
or we can
anticipate where are variants coming
from which ones are going to be of
concern
and not you know at the moment they
appear that's not
how this virus works and that's not how
our response to the pandemic will work
and it's not how we will work as we try
to unlock our country
yes but i mean there is a big question
and we you know it is a big if
we don't know what's going to happen in
the next few weeks
but there's certainly a possibility
because this is so much more
transmissible
that actually not acting in a in a
stricter way
now could mean that the 21st of june
just goes out the window
no not necessarily i mean the big thing
that we have not necessarily but i mean
forgive me even the prime minister
admits that's a possibility
and of course everything in the future
is a possibility you can only deal with
the evidence you have at the time
of course that's the case you know these
plays on words are not that helpful
but you know of course anything can
happen but what we're doing
is we have the biggest vaccination
program
as you know we've got the country with
the most uh take up
a vaccine which is which has actually
put us in an extremely
good position and actually in bolton and
um in blackburn right now we've got many
many more people
coming forward for the vaccine and
that's great news so
that's our key message is get the job
when you're asked we're getting to you
as soon as possible
and hopefully we'll get to all adults in
the uk uh before the end of july
um you know that's that's our that's our
mission that's our goal that's what
we're doing
and that is what's protecting us
ultimately and the case rates at the
moment it's just over two thousand
to two thousand two hundred in our cases
um you know clearly
we are worried about it it growing
because we saw what happened with with
the kent variant you know once these
variants become
highly transmissible they do translate
very quickly but we're in a very
different place with the vaccine
than we were uh in december when we
first identified
the the kemp variant i mean what should
people do in terms of traveling we've
got the green list of course
you know all well and good what about
the amber list here
should people be going to an amber list
country
no there's some special circumstances
that you're allowed to which is why
they're on the amber list
which is um you know for business for
from for um morning funerals those kind
of things
for serious serious uh individual cases
with
you know family health etc but uh by and
large uh what we're saying is uh
you know the ambulance is it's not to go
on holiday not for uh pleasure travel at
the moment
but it's not illegal to do so anymore is
it there no fines attack should you want
to do that
no and to be honest it's not in
legislation this is guidance from the
government you know we haven't uh we
haven't legislated
to ban people from going on holiday at
all this is guidance and as in many of
these things that we've
had throughout the pandemic this has
been about uh really
allowing on the the great british public
um
you know relying on them being sensible
and looking at the guidance that we put
in place and taking their own decisions
really um
but no we wouldn't advise going on
holiday to the ambulance countries
yeah we understand 150 flights it's been
reported actually by some
some uh media groups 150 flights
departed to ambulance countries on
monday people are
people are wanting to go they're going
to go aren't they
um i don't think there's that many
people going on holiday right now which
is why you hear from the travel industry
a lot i worked in the travel industry
many years so i i know that's the case
but there's many reasons you know
there's no way um you know we're very
highly international island um you know
we're very very integrated and connected
with many
many places so there's lots of trade
there's lots of business travel there's
lots of people
who you know who do come from our
country
even when you've got travel um you know
bands in place or you've got travel
restrictions in place that's the kind of
country we are which is why
our strategy for the global pandemic has
not been
to try and completely lock down all of
our borders
from the beginning and not let anybody
in and not let anybody out that works
for some countries
you've seen some countries exercise that
that doesn't work for our country
our strategy is to vaccinate everybody
and to then cautiously open up our
economy and then
hopefully we can start to get back to
normal with a system
that enables us to with the best genome
sequencing system in the world
identify those variants obviously we
have very tough
measures at the border you have to take
a test one day
before you come and on day two forgive
me i mean
i mean there's a lot of scientists not
all but a lot of
of the leading scientists on this are
saying look
banning flights from india would have
been a sensible move
i mean i mean even with hindsight now
can't you say
well yeah perhaps we should have looked
at that well we did
we did actually stop we put them on the
red list
two weeks before we identified that
variant and the reason we did that was
because of rising case numbers
and obviously they had rising testing
which was enabling them to see that but
also
the positive test everybody who flies
here before you fly here you have to
have a negative test and then you have
to have a test on day two
and test on day eight because of course
you may miss
actually the viral load that is a very
tough system and that's actually
how we got the data to identify this
variant
good to talk to you this morning thank
you thank you very much
i just want to bring you some breaking
news and the inflation figures for april
have just been released by the office
for national statistics
let's find out what they are from our
economics and data editor
ed conway morning ed
morning inflation of course is is the
key measure of just how fast prices are
rising around the economy and of course
during the pandemic uh it fell quite
sharply it's a pretty good
measure of just how much spending is
going on and what kind of activity is
happening
and of course the bank of england uh its
job is to try and keep inflation as
close as possible
to two percent so any time it's kind of
varying away from that or anytime it's
moving sharply
people get a little bit concerned and
what you can probably see here this this
chart just shows you the latest numbers
but also going back
the last few years and you can see that
in the period
over the pandemic so that area in the
last few months
it was really weak it was quite low down
uh getting close to zero
but what's happened in the latest month
so the latest data that we have
uh is showing that it went up from 0.7
percent which was quite low
to 1.5 percent now that's a very big
increase when you're talking about month
or month
changes the kinds of things that have
contributed to this uh household items
clothing as well uh utility bills have
started to push it up
uh as well and if you just look simply
at the difference between last month uh
so the previous month which is march
and april uh that is one of the biggest
increases month or month that we've seen
in this index and some people might look
at that and say well there is cause
for concern here although it's quite far
still below that bank of england target
of uh
two percent uh there are concerns around
the world that what with governments
pushing so much money
into the economy to try to get it going
including not just in this country but
in the us as well even more so
that might start to push up prices
that's happened in the us where they
have inflation of
over four percent now uh and so the
question is whether the bank of england
is going to look at this and start
thinking well it is time
uh to be concerned about this
nonetheless still below
that two percent target uh but rising
relatively quickly now
okay ed thank you
now there have been reports the israeli
military has launched new attacks
on gaza overnight with hamas firing
rockets back across the border while the
continued fighting comes despite
growing international calls for an end
to the violence
at least 218 people including 63
children have now been killed in gaza
12 people killed in israel let's get the
latest from alex rossi
who's in jerusalem i mean i mean the
fact that these are continuing
still alex despite these calls for more
diplomacy it's hugely disturbing
yeah the israeli defense force said it
would be an intensive night of bombing
again
in gaza they have been attacking
uh what they have called the metro
system this is the
underground system of tunnels that hamas
fighters and other palestinian militants
use to get around the coastal
enclave underground and launch rockets
and mortar fire
into israel now we've also heard
sirens ringing out again across southern
israel barrages of rockets have been
fired
throughout the night so no let up in the
fighting
but the diplomacy continues albeit at a
very slow pace yesterday the united
nations security council met
again but reached no conclusion
interestingly
the french in coordination with the
jordanians and the egyptians have now
filed
a resolution at the security council
but that could take some time because
the wording will need to be very precise
and very careful
otherwise it may very well be vetoed by
the united states which has already
blocked
three statements at the u.n but of
course the humanitarian situation the
suffering continues
uh particularly in gaza the
number of dead now 218 including
a hundred women and children according
to the gazan health ministry
uh basic services are becoming at the
point of near total claps fuel supplies
are running out some supplies did get in
yesterday through the karim shalom
crossing which is run by israel 24
trucks of
medical supplies and food but that was
very quickly closed
after palestinian rockets and mortar
fire hit that position so
a pretty depressing scene really here uh
this morning
uh that we are seeing across uh this
area
no signs yet of a ceasefire the hope of
course is the diplomacy
will win out sooner rather than later
okay alex thank you
now india has recorded another record
day for covet 19 deaths reporting
4529 fatalities it brings the country's
total death toll from the virus to two
hundred and eighty three thousand
two hundred and forty eight india has
now recorded more than
twenty five million cases of kovid 19.
france will begin the next stage of its
phase reopening today
restaurants cinemas museums and
non-essential shops are amongst the
venues
that can welcome people back math
squaring is currently still obligatory
in all
indoor and outdoor public spaces across
the country
spain has deployed its military to
patrol the border with morocco after
about 8 000
migrants crossed into the country a
sudden influx of migrants swimming
into this spanish enclave in northern
africa
has resulted in a has resulted in a
humanitarian crisis
people needing to be rescued from the
sea suffering from exhaustion
and hypothermia the new york attorney
general's office has opened a criminal
investigation
into former president donald trump's
property company
the attorney general leticia james has
been investigating whether
the trump organization falsely reported
property values
to secure loans and obtain economic
benefits
the trump organization denies any
wrongdoing
well let's return now to the spread of
the indian variant of kovid 19. one
so-called hot spot is bedford where 80
confirmed cases of the variant have
already been found
many of these infections are in those
who are yet to receive a vaccine
including young people and school
children becky johnson reports
now on the effects that rising
infections are having on schools in the
area
in places where the indian variant is
spreading rapidly
it's young people who are catching it in
large numbers
here in bedford a spike in cases has hit
schools
at bedford academy many classrooms are
almost
empty with a quarter of pupils at home
isolating
we've had nearly um 50 cases in the last
five weeks since we've returned since
half term
previously in the heart and before that
we've probably had four or five cases
that were confirmed in the school so in
terms of isolation we've probably had
upwards of 500 students that have been
self-isolating over the last five-week
period
300 of those have been over the last two
weeks
pupils that are still in school worry
they'll be next
you can just see people coming in and
now um having to go back
home because they've been in close
contact so it is quite worrying
the rapid spread of the indian variant
here in bedford is mainly in people
under 40 which on the one hand is good
news because it suggests
older people are being protected by the
vaccine
but for those yet to have their jab who
still have to mix at work or at school
it's a big worry fifteen-year-old eva
was sent home to isolate after a
classmate tested positive
it is quite worrying because because
most of like our year is
asymptomatic i could be like just
walking around
and just be and then transmitting it to
someone who could then be really
seriously affected by
it i don't want to catch it i don't want
my friends and family to catch it either
teaching unions warn what's happening in
bedford
could be repeated elsewhere my guess is
there will be other new variants of
future points so what's the plan from
government around all of this
it just seems to me the assumption that
we don't have to worry about things
uh is really unhelpful and in particular
those young people
in lots of schools who are having to
self-isolate and at the same time know
that they should be in school doing
their assessments because their exams
are going to be making judgments about
them this year
they are particularly concerned young
people
are still trying to catch up after so
much time has been lost
but unprotected by vaccines they now
risk spreading a variant that's
even more contagious and difficult to
contain
becky johnson sky news in bedford
okay let's see what the weather's gonna
do for you today it was a
bit grim yesterday certainly where i
live is it any better today nas
um a bit better later actually uh but
it's almost like
the calm before the storm because we are
going to see
very wet and windy conditions through
tomorrow and friday
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning well hiding behind me is an
area of low pressure that is uh moving
in off the atlantic
and through tonight tomorrow and friday
it's going to bring
very wet and windy conditions across
much of the uk and ireland
until then it's a case of sunshine and
showers today this morning though it's
cloudy with showery rain across parts of
central southeastern england that will
clear away off into the north sea uh
before midday and some patchy rain
across northern and eastern parts of
scotland moving down towards the central
belt elsewhere
sunny spells and showers but later a
high pressure building from the west so
fewer showers across western areas and
some central parts
so the main focus of the showers today
will be across northern and eastern
areas and much like previous days
they will be heavy and thundery before
the wet and windy weather
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast we'll talk to the shadow
health secretary
jonathan ashworth about his concerns
over the spread
of the indian variant
it's time to call it out for what it is
i call these police departments the clue
quest playing with badgers on
oh my god i
guilty guilty
well i think one of the things that
we've all realized during this pandemic
is how important our well-being and our
mental health is now of course it's
important to separate
mental illness from well-being and
health and but i think all of us have
wanted to
um take control i think and do a bit
more to look after ourselves
ultimately and you know whether that's
getting outside more often
catching some natural light exercising
communicating with those that we hold
dear
and making sure we're managing our
stress effectively we're sleeping well
all these things play a part into
how we feel and so you know that's why i
wrote the book level every day i wanted
to kind of bring
the science out there my personal
experience and my professional
experience and put that together into
i guess key chapters that people
hopefully can can use to improve their
own
health and ultimately feel feel better
from it i think it's
it's been different for everyone
everyone is different everyone's an
individual
and i think the pandemic in whatever way
has put pressure on everyone whether
you're on the front line working in
a in a e or you're working as a carer or
whether you're at home
shielding um you know and there's so
many people that have
felt so much stress and pressure for
different reasons or isolation
and it's impacted everyone you know and
if you look at um even you know the
road map at the moment people going back
you know coming out of this pandemic
some people are really wanting to rush
back to
busy shops and get going again others
are much more cautious and
i think it's i think this pandemic has
really really taught us to listen to the
way we feel
and do things in the way that we're
comfortable uh
to do especially going back to you know
normality you know take things at your
own
time and look after yourself i really
really really hope that a lot of things
we've learned from this pandemic about
self-care
about investing in yourself and your own
time your own energy will take that
forward after the pandemic because a lot
of us been burned the candle
at both ends far too long
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now the government says it's relying on
the british public to be
sensible and take responsibility when
traveling abroad
the education minister gillian keegan
told me short time ago it's not illegal
for people to travel to amber listed
countries
but the government would advise against
it
it's not in legislation this is guidance
from the government you know we haven't
we haven't legislated to ban people from
going on holiday
at all this is guidance and as in many
of these things that we've
had throughout the pandemic this has
been about really
allowing on the the great british public
um
you know relying on them being sensible
and looking at the guidance that we put
in place and taking their own decisions
really um
but no we wouldn't advise going on
holiday to the ambulance countries
let's talk to our political
correspondent kate mccann and
in some respects that's not overly
helpful is it i mean people are wanting
to go abroad
and they're not actually being told what
to do just make it make up your own mind
but we don't advise it
i think there was a really interesting
phrase actually that jillian keegan used
in that interview which was that we're
moving into a stage of cautious personal
responsibility and you're so right
because people's risk
balance is going to be completely
different depending on how they feel
some people
you know we were talking before we came
on air some people will have been
creeped up in a small flat for the last
year or so and a holiday will be really
important to them so they might think
that it's
you know less of a risk to take that
holiday than other people might
and this is the problem the government
now has because you can't keep making
really restrictive policy forever
at some point you do have to move into a
stage where people are taking the
decisions into their own hands case
numbers are still relatively low
deaths thankfully are the same too but
the concern at the moment is the lack of
data i think
we just don't know how well the vaccine
is acting against this indian variant we
don't know whether
the vaccination surge program is going
to be enough to hold it in some of these
areas where we're seeing it
gather pace and that's the problem for
the government that's why we're on this
watch and wait brief and that's why the
prime minister and his ministers
are still hesitant when it comes to
whether or not that june 21st opening
date is going to happen
okay kate thank you well the shadow
health secretary jonathan ashworth
is here in the studio good to see you
this morning look in terms of
of of travel advice i mean what's the
labour party's take on all of this
because
it's not illegal to travel to an amber
country for a holiday
the government has changed that now but
advising us not to go anyway
it is a bit confusing it is a bit
confusing and i think people just want
clarity
because people want to do the right
thing i mean i mean people feeling so
desperate there are people who want will
want a holiday i mean i was in house
comments on monday and
matt hancock was asked explicitly about
this should people go on holiday if the
country's on the ambulance he said no
no they shouldn't and another tory mp
jumped up and said well you've
effectively made the amber list
the red list so people just want clear
guidance about what is the right thing
to do would you go
no no i wouldn't i wouldn't i mean at
the moment i'm planning on going on
holiday i suspect it's a sort of devon
or cornwall or somewhere
if i do get a holiday this summer with
my kids but i
i probably wouldn't have uh um
introduced the
the the travel the international travel
uh restrictions
easing this week and i've done it in a
different way but our
homes actually nick thomas simmons has
been long been calling on
on your program and other programs that
we need a comprehensive
border policy i mean our borders have
been about as secure as a sieve
throughout this crisis and it's why
we're seeing these variants bounce
bounce at us that variants bounce across
the world and they come and hit us and
there's probably gonna be more of this
as well so uh we've got to work
internationally to bring infection rates
down and to uh
make sure that the world is vaccinated
but we've also got to have secure
borders and controls as well
well look i mean there are lots of
arguments over whether
more should be done to stop travel from
india at an early day i mean it's it's
not even stopped now but the indian
variant is here yes
what should we be doing i i think
there's a number of things now we've got
to do to
quickly contain this variant that boris
we understand and i understand that
boris johnson can't
give you a cast iron guarantee around
june 21st and i wouldn't expect him to
you know we've got to be grown-ups this
is a period of uncertainty but what he
can do
is take all necessary action now to try
and protect that june 21st date
so i would do more vaccination in the
areas the bedfords the bolsons the black
burns i'd really surge it
for everybody i'd give the local
councils the resources to do enhanced
contact tracing i'd make sure that
premises and buildings have air
filtration
and ventilation support systems in place
and crucially i would pay people
decent sick pay and financial support so
they can isolate we've still got a
situation
whereas if you are low paid and not
eligible for decent sick pay
you are forced with that choice of
either going to work
when ill or staying at home and not
being able to pay your bills
that is not fair the problem is when you
when you listen to the scientists
they have concerns over surge
vaccinations not that it won't work
but it's not going to work for at least
three weeks so
you know under those circumstances and i
know it's hugely unpopular
do these areas need to be locked down
for the next three weeks
well i mean i hear different points of
view from scientists and public health
directors some say because you're
dealing with a younger cohort of people
that the vaccination will begin to take
effect within a week week to 10 days so
there is a different
there are different opinions out there
but i think that i i
you know i'm the mp for leicester i live
in leicester you know we've been the
city that was locked down for a year
a lot all right we came out of lockdown
we're winning the fa cup so were you
pleased about that but
i know how difficult local lockdowns are
i don't want to see bolton and bedford
and blackburn
going to local lockdowns we tried
whack-a-mole that's when boris johnson
used to say that was the approach
but he can take action now to avoid that
yeah
i mean it's the problem is with all of
this whatever is decided by the
government
on this there's always going to be
alternatives that will come forward as a
criticism now
you've got to accept that haven't you as
an opposition that there is there is no
perfect answer to this you know it's not
as though
the government hasn't got the answers
and you have it
it is quite simply a difference of of
approach isn't it
well as i say throughout this crisis
i've always tried to adopt
a grown-up sensible approach because
we're dealing with uncertainties
we are dealing with dilemmas and i
understand
that but there are a number of things
that we've not done as a country
that have been done in other countries
across the world who have been more
successful in their response
and it does come down to things like
sick pay isolation support making
sure that some countries offer for
example hotel rooms for people to
isolate themselves
from their families if they live in uh
you know
congested housing there's lots of things
that we could have tried
which other countries have tried which
we never did what about i mean
her name escapes me at the moment but
one of the the key members of the sage
group
saying because of the indian variant
being a variant of concern we didn't
meet the four tests
to reduce the lockdown last monday
would you agree with that would you have
would you would you have gone ahead with
this week as
we have done no no we were we were going
ahead we were we were backing the call
to go ahead because i think when there's
so many
uh you know businesses have invested so
much in preparing for monday
you know we've got to understand the
economic consequences of these decisions
that's not to say
that you're putting the economy ahead of
ahead of dealing with covert it's a
recognition that
economic outcomes and health health
outcomes are interlinked
but if you're going to go ahead with
easings like we've done
you've got to make sure your
fundamentals are in place like
sick pay and ventilation and air
filtration systems i mean
there's experts now who have developed
technology which improves the air
quality in supermarkets and big sort of
pubs and so on and though and those
premises those businesses should be
getting grants
should be getting support from
government to install this new
technology
look we're running out of time but can i
ask about the
the internal review into the handling of
the pandemic because i know you want the
government to to publish that
information why do you think that's
important to hear that now because i
think transparency improves
decision making and as it happens it's
not just me saying it's now mr dominic
cummings perhaps surprising
that i would be agreeing with dominic
cummings given the last 12 months but
dominic cummings is saying all these
things should be published because when
you get
proper transparency when you can
scrutinize government decisions in real
time
it leads to better governance it leads
to better decision making and i think
better decision making
is in the national interest look really
good to talk to you this morning thank
you
now new figures have been released today
showing the extent of child
poverty in the uk data from the last
five years show that even before the
pandemic 4.3 million children
were living in poverty well let's talk
to ali fortescue who's got the latest
from the newsroom so what are these
latest figures showing ellie
well they're pretty stark and crucially
they're from before the pandemic so they
just define a household in poverty as a
household
that has less than 60 of the average
family
income so that would be a household of
one adult two children
with less than 280 pounds a week after
paying for housing most of these
families they say are single parent
households
and the problem is starkist in cities so
places like
london and birmingham in london for
example there are eight constituencies
where the majority of children more than
half of children
are living in poverty uh of the nations
they say
uh the problem is uh starkist in wales
where there are 31 of children living in
poverty the northeast of england showed
the biggest growth
in child property they said over the
last five years rising by more than a
third now they say this is largely down
to
rising house prices stagnating wages
and as you say um are figures from
before the pandemic and we spoke to one
mother who said that for her the
situation
since then has gone got a lot worse
children were out of school for a long
time there are a lot of parents
that aren't entitled to free school
meals and yet they're still struggling
to put meals on the table week in week
out
so that divide with food poverty has
been huge
also um i mean when you look at kind of
like the technological
divide my daughter was working from a
mobile phone and she did that for
months because i don't have a laptop or
a computer at home
and there are there are hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of families that
were doing that up and down the country
and this all plays into uncomfortable
debates for the government about things
like free school meals things like
ending the temporary uplift to universal
credit
they say that child poverty according to
their measure has actually been
improving but undoubtedly
this is uncomfortable reading
particularly when it comes
to the rising poverty that this research
suggests is happening
in the northeast for a government that
say that they are all about leveling up
the country
okay ali thank you we'll sort of come on
sky news breakfast the reusable face
mask
with some alarming flaws at least
according to which
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten
front line they are dying here
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
phillip no
go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations to philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christchurch has been changed
forever by what happened
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to
the safety rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all out politics podcast
for the listeners
from sky news story cast sky news
podcasts
listen and subscribe for free did you
know
symptoms of hay fever can develop at any
stage of life not just in childhood
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
sunshine and showers are on the cards
once again for today and some of the
showers will be again heavy and thundery
there will also be cloudy skies and
patchy rain sinking southwards from the
north of scotland to the central belt
through the day
however later western parts of the uk
island will become
drier and brighter tree pollen continues
to be airborne with oak but birch is in
decline
some grass pollen is also airborne now
so in regards to the levels most places
will be moderate today but
high for the northeast of england and
the northeast of scotland continues to
have low levels of pollen for today
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
we're all a bit fed up of these aren't
we but we know we've got to wear them
now this is this is i'm using these
disposable ones the problem with them
at the moment though is how did you get
rid of them safely this is that causing
a lot of concern actually so a lot of
people wearing
the reusable ones sounds all good but do
they work as well well new research from
consumer group which has revealed some
alarming flaws and the effectiveness of
many widely
available reusable face masks one
popular one was found to
block only a third of potentially
harmful particles well let's talk to the
head of campaigns at which
nina batty good to see you this morning
so what have you discovered here
so we looked at a range of popular
brands and styles of face coverings
and masks which were reusable and are
widely available from pharmacies high
street stores supermarkets and online
retailers
our scientists tested reusable masks for
how well they filtered particles how
breathable they were
and how they fared after multiple washes
but as you rightly said we found
a wide range in effectiveness all the
way from being able to block
99 of potentially harmful bacterias
um all the way to only a third of
particles being blocked
uh in the worst performing masks in some
respects
does it matter in that i mean obviously
something is better that anything is
better than nothing and the government
only says we have to wear a face
covering so if it's not totally
effective
is that a huge issue
i think what was worrying for us was
that there were high filtration claims
made on the packaging
of these masks um and yet they didn't
live up to tests so if people
are looking for maximum effectiveness
and protection because they are worried
actually what they're able to buy isn't
really clear for them
um and they aren't actually living up to
the claims that they're making
we also saw poor packaging instructions
across a range
of these masks which actually could um
again
inhibit the maximum effectiveness all
the way from how you should be using the
mask
so that you can be as safe as possible
and then also those washing instructions
if they are reusable you want to be able
to wash them
what happens after you've washed them a
couple of times what happens to that
effectiveness
so really the key thing here is that are
these um
products that are housed in the market
really living up to those claims so
people can
make their own decisions about how
effective they want their masks to be
okay so which ones caused particular
concern for you
so one of the uh most popular ones we
saw was um the adidas face covering
it's widely available from stores like
asos next
sports direct but that only blocked a
third of potentially harmful bacterial
particles
um whereas the best performing that we
saw
was the air pop pocket and it's a
semi-reusable mask
but it had up to 99 filtration
effectiveness
so you can really see the wide disparity
of mass that you can find on the market
and really means that people need to do
a lot of research before they
they look to buy a mask yeah i mean
adidas said our face cover was designed
for the general public and he's not
medically graded but it can help limit
the spread of droplets
i mean so i mean they're not making
overreaching claims are they
no they're not but i think in the last
year there's been a lot of focus
on the standards on non-medical face
coverings we all
know that we have to use masks not
necessarily in medical masks
but um there is a development of
standards which which has been a part of
and really what this shows is that needs
to be more oversight to ensure that the
basic standards and requirements of
these non-medical face coverings
are met and so people can have
confidence when they're shopping that at
least i will get
a base minimum protection when i buy any
mask
um in stores what about the i mean
what's what did you make of the boots
mask
because i mean they've said they've got
full confidence in the filtration claims
it's been rigorously tested and
continues to achieve 95
filtration for 10 washes does that then
do your results disagree with that
our results have shown that actually it
doesn't live up to what boots claims
um you know it'd be interesting to see
those test results but our tests have
shown that
they haven't lived up to the claims
according to what's on their packaging
and also how they perform in terms of um
after washes we also looked at how
breathable
these products were and how they as i
said how they fared after those multiple
washes and what their effectiveness went
down so
um our tests have shown something
different um around the boots mask
okay nina good to torture this morning
thank you
okay time for a check on the weather for
you now here's naz
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
morning to you hiding behind me is an
area of low pressure out in the atlantic
that is going to be heading its way
towards the uk and island from tonight
and spread eastwards through tomorrow
and friday bringing with a
very wet and windy conditions until then
it's looking like sunshine and showers
once again for today and this morning
it's showery spells or rain and cloudy
skies for many central
and southeastern parts of england but
with the cloud cover there
it's not as cold as elsewhere where it's
mainly dry and sunny but
chilly with a frost in some spots also
not so cold across the northeast of
scotland where there's cloud and patchy
rain that will be sinking its way
southwards to central parts of scotland
later
the cloud and rain across the southeast
will clear away by midday but then we're
seeing sunshine and showers for most
places although
later western areas will become a bit
dry as high pressure builds briefly
before that low pressure system comes in
with wet and windy weather tonight
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast treating the pandemics teenage
victims
we hear from the mental health nurses
caring for young people
amid a surge in self-harm and eating
disorders it's a disturbing report but
it's worth watching
a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my name's ella i'm an environmental
activist and founder of the
end period plastic campaign you might be
thinking why period products
what's so bad about them they're the
fifth most common item
found polluting europe's beaches they're
more commonly found
than straws or coffee cups
[Music]
you